the Miami Book Fair but just a few
minutes ago senator Bernie Sanders
arrived at the c-span bus which is
parked here on the campus of miami-dade
College to do a call-in program to talk
about his newest book our revolution a
future to believe in senator Sanders you
write this from page 167 that the
Clinton campaign may not have liked it
the Democratic establishment may not
have liked it but it was becoming
increasingly clear that I was the
strongest candidate if Democrats were to
retain the White House well that's what
all of the polling showed what the
polling showed is state-by-state in
almost all cases not all and nationally
I was running a better than Secretary
Clinton against mr. Trump and in some
cases what Billy big numbers the last
couple of months on our calling programs
on c-span we've heard from a lot of
Sanders supporters who say I was
supporting Bernie Sanders but when he
dropped out I'm now supporting Donald
Trump how does that connect well it
connects in the sense that important
reality in this country today that media
has missed and that many politicians
have missed is that a lot of people are
in a lot of pain we have a middle class
which is in decline you have roughly
half of older workers today B half who
have nothing in the bank as they move
into retirement they're scared to death
you got elderly people cutting their
prescription front pills in half you got
moms out there can't afford child care
for their kids you got
kids graduating college today 50
$100,000 in debt and making 12 bucks an
hour can't pay up that that is a reality
which the media has kind of missed and
most politicians have kindness it's not
a reality that I have missed and
throughout my entire political career
that's what I have been talking about
that there is something fundamentally
wrong when in the richest country in
history of the world which is what we
are today the middle class continues to
decline 43 million people live in
poverty and almost all new income and
wealth is going to the top 1% they were
moving toward an oligarchic form of
society and now it's been my message and
I mr. Trump comes along and he says well
you know the establishment isn't working
yeah I'm a multi-billionaire as mr.
Trump but you know I'm going to take on
the establishment I'm going to take on
the politicians and I'm going to take on
Wall Street I'm going to take on the
drug companies and I can do it and I'm
the only one by the way who can do it
and people responded to that so I think
to mr. Trump's credit what he understood
is there is a lot of anger and pain and
frustration out there now we have a long
list of all of the things that mr. Trump
promised during this campaign and we are
going to introduce I mean many of these
ideas or ideas that I and others have
been talking about for a long time well
we're going to see to what degree he was
telling the American people the truth or
to what degree these were simply
campaign rhetoric of which he had no
intention to fulfill but we have been
oppress them we're going to introduce
legislation and we hope that he works
with us in fulfilling his own campaign
promises now senator Bernie Sanders will
be speaking at the Miami Book Fair and
about a little over an hour and we will
be covering that live on book TV so this
is your chance to talk with them the
numbers are on the screen 202 is the
area code seven four eight eighty two
hundred for those of you in the East and
Central time zones seven four eight
eight two zero one if you live in the
mountain and Pacific time zones this is
your fourth book when did you have a
chance to write not much not much I
wrote it up to the campaign we took a
very little bit of time off after the
campaign and I spent three months
working very long and hard I was on the
book if you had been elected president
you talked about this in the book would
would you have had to raise taxes for
some of the programs that you've got
some advocated for absolutely at a time
when you have billionaires like Donald
Trump not paying a nickel in federal
income tax at a time when you had major
corporation at the major corporation of
putting they're stashing their profits
in the Cayman Islands another tax a
and in a given year after making
billions of dollars in profits not
paying a penny in federal corporate
taxes of course we can demand that those
people pay their fair share of taxes one
of the concerns that I have and I've
said this god knows how many times is
the grotesque level of income and wealth
inequality that we have today you got
the top one-tenth of 1% owning almost as
much wealth as the bottom 90%
anybody think that's what America is
supposed to be about 52% of all new
income today goes to the top 1% that has
got to change and I will do my best as
the United States Senator to make those
changes page 51 of our revolution the
Clintons over the years received huge
amounts of money in campaign
contributions and speaking fees from
powerful financial interests in
corporate America whether it was on the
campaign trail or in their private lives
they spent an enormous amount of time
raising money from the wealthy and the
powerful yes
I don't think that's desirable but is
that the state of the Democratic Party
well that's a good question people and
I'm glad you brought it there because
that is exactly what I'm working on
right now say I think that mr. Trump's
many and most of the people who voted
for mr. Trump I don't think they're
racist I don't think they're sexist I
think that they are people in
desperation who are hurting and they are
in pain and they look around and they
say what is the Democratic Party doing
for me now the truth is and this is an
important truth is that today after
eight years of President Obama our
economy is in much better shape than it
was when Bush left office not just a
fact which left office you'll recall
that we were losing 800,000 jobs a month
our world's financial system was on the
verge of collapse we're running up a 1.4
trillion dollar deficit the largest in
American history are we better off today
of course we are and Obama deserves
credit for that but and here is the very
big but is that while that improvement
has taken place it has not been enough
too many people are still hurting you
got millions of workers today who in
real inflation accounted for dollars are
making less the
they made 40 years ago and their thing
what's going on why am i working longer
hours for low wages I'm falling for the
guy
and they're worried to death about their
children will their children ever get a
decent job so those are the so you know
in my view Obama has made progress but
not enough and it is time for the
Democratic Party to undergo a
fundamental change and decide which side
it's on you can't get money from Wall
Street and you can't coddle the
pharmaceutical industry you got to stand
with the working families of this
country the vast majority of the people
and tell Wall Street that we're going to
break up these large banks that they
agreed and elate illegal behavior is
unacceptable we're going to tell the
pharmaceutical industry to stop ripping
off the people of this country five
major drug companies last year made
fifty billion dollars in profit and you
got millions of people can't afford the
medicine they desperately need so
there's a lot of work that has to be
done but the Democratic Party has to go
into go a transformation and make it
clear which side you are you can't get
huge amounts of money from Wall Street
and say I'm on the side of working
families as a newest member of the
Democratic leadership team in the Senate
how will you affect that change is what
I'm thinking about right now but what
that change will be about in my view and
what I want to see happen is the
transformation of the Democratic Party
to be a party which really is a
grassroots party which opens up its law
to working people and says yes we know
that you can't make it on ten bucks an
hour we know that you are hurting as
your job went to China or to Mexico we
know you can't afford to send your kids
to college stand with us be part of us
and open the door to young people a
Peter if there is anything that
impressed me in my campaign is the
opportunity to speak to so many very
beautiful young people of everyone
watching is pessimistic about the future
of this country above and beyond the
recent election we got to know that
there's a generation of young people out
there who are very beautiful people who
really love this country who are going
to work hard to make this country become
what we know it can be
come this is a generation which is the
least the least racist generationally
sexist generation least homophobic
generation in the history of our country
most the generation most concerned about
the environment and climate change it is
a very beautiful group of people and we
want to bring them in to the Democratic
Party senator Sanders newest book is
called our revolution here's the cover
let's hear from Margaret and Leavenworth
Kansas Margaret you're on with senator
Sanders first of all thank you so much
for running I worry your t-shirt I had
to be in Kansas than I used to live in
Chicago I was very shocked you're very
wrong sir when you say there's not
racist and things here was like people
still talking about Obama as a socialist
a communist people using religions to
hate gays I was very proud of the two
Democrats that one in the Brownback
hostel Kansas but my question is I'm 66
I can't hit the streets anymore I've had
breast cancer I'm so afraid that Social
Security and Medicare is going to be
taken away and I don't know how much
more poverty I can still manage the
sisters of charity help me here there's
no public transportation I get 16
dollars of food stamps a month it's
health care that I know is not the
greatest
there's nothing nowhere to go toward the
bottom that are Mary Margaret liver
Joyce thank you let me just say this in
terms of your first point I am more than
aware that racism and sexism exists in
America my point was that I think that
wasn't the dominant reason that mr.
Trump won but let me get to your second
point and this is an important point we
are going to hold mr. Trump accountable
you know he ran for president the
Democrat Republican primary and he sent
out a tweet if I'm not mistaken and he
said I am the only Republican candidate
over there speak 1917 chemisty 16
candidates I am the only case
they running Republican primary who does
not believe that we should cut Social
Security Medicare or Medicaid Donald
Trump I will not cut Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid
now what Margaret's point is which is
absolutely right is they got most
Republicans out there in the Congress
level but most of them do want to cut
Social Security Medicare Medicaid and
give huge tax breaks to billionaires but
we are going the whole Trump accountable
we are going to hold them to his word I
myself believe we should expand Social
Security because people can't make it on
eleven and twelve thousand dollars a
year but we will hold Trump accountable
he said he will not cut Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid and I will do
everything that I can to make sure that
he does not cut Social Security Medicare
or Medicaid Stephen Canfield Ohio go
ahead hey there this question for Bernie
about third party I am seeing a big
business on through major powers of the
Democrats and the Republican parties I
just want to why Bernie stay with the
Democratic Party and not instead helping
to lead a movement to form a new party
when you look at Thank You Steven Bernie
Sanders Eve that's a fair question and I
think as I trust many of the viewers
though I am the longest serving
independent in the history of the United
States Congress I was elected mayor of
Burlington Vermont as an independent
defeating Democrats and Republicans and
so forth I know a little bit about it
and what I do know is that it is very
very very hard to put together a strong
third party and right now where I am is
trying to significantly change and
transform and reform the Democratic
Party to make it a party of working
people of young people a party which is
going to stand up to the fossil fuel
industry and wall street and the drug
companies and the insurance companies we
are the wealthiest country in the
history of the world we should not have
to receive calls from people like
Margaret who are wondering how they're
going to survive unlimited amounts of
money in Social Security that's not what
this country should
about so right now that is where I am
and I am going to do everything I can to
make sure that the Democratic Party has
the guts to stand up to the big money
interests who have so much power over
the economic and political life of this
country but now that you've joined
leadership are you senator Bernie
Sanders D Vermont or I've Vermont I was
elected as an independent that's what I
am IVA is in New London Iowa I have a go
ahead with your question or comment for
Bernie Sanders
yes Mr Sanders the first place I don't
trust Donald Trump he lies every breath
he takes and he scares me to death
I think he wants two classes of people
the rich and the poor and the rich and
the poor that's what they have in
communism there's this fright you and he
or you really think that the government
can control him
no he makes me look I spent the last two
weeks of the campaign going to 12 states
around this country including Iowa doing
my best to see the Donald Trump lost
that election so of course he frightens
me and the people that he has around him
make me very very nervous but we are
where we are right now and what I can
say is that in a democratic society
people can disagree on a lot of issues
but where there can in my view be no
compromise is on the issue of bigotry we
have a Trump who has a record of having
led the so-called birther movement and
let's be clear that so-called birther
movement was a racist effort to
undermine the first African American
president in our history you could
disagree with Obama all you want but to
try to undermine his legitimacy through
the so-called birther movement is
grotesque and unacceptable so we're
going to keep our eye on mr. Trump in
terms of his relationship to African
Americans his ideas and in the
statements that he made about the Latino
community accusing Latinos of being
criminals and rapists and as immigration
thoughts about sweeping up millions of
people throwing them out of this country
unacceptable his views on Islam one of
the largest
legions in the world and this
unconstitutional idea that we can keep
people have a certain religion from
entering the United States all of those
issues should be a great concern to
every American and fighting to make sure
that we remain a non-discriminatory
society we have come a long way in
fighting discrimination and we are not
going back when I can have a racist
sexist type of society we've got to go
forward page 292 of our revolution
President Obama is a friend of mine I
have worked with him on many issues but
on the issue of trade he has been dead
wrong
yes not only him in my view when we talk
about why the middle class of this
country has been shrinking why we have
seen thousands and thousands of
factories shut down over the last 20
years that has a lot to do with our
disastrous trade policies nobody should
be fooled these trade policies are
created and written by corporate America
by the pharmaceutical industry by the
big-money interests and the function of
those trade policies by enlarge is to
allow corporations to shut down in the
United States move to China Mexico and
other low-wage countries I helped lead
the effort against the TPP the
trans-pacific partnership I am delighted
but that is dead we need a new trade
policy which benefits American workers
and not just the CEOs of large
corporations next call for senator
Bernie Sanders comes from Adrienne and
West Covina California Adrienne your own
book TV hello Mr Sanders we're listening
please go ahead oh yes um I just had a
question I don't really trust Donald
Trump with the people he has surrounded
himself with the be whole counsel
national policy people of the Christian
Zionists the Warhawks and and I just
want to well first off say to you that I
agree with your
all your looks on trade and the war Iraq
and your vote against the Patriot Act
and things that you know you've shown
that you know you are which you stand
for and you're here for that but my my
question is do you believe that's why
you were railroaded with the DNC because
of your voting record and you know the
way you've shown that you and for pretty
much what's right look the DNC is part
of the establishment and during the
course of the campaign as I think many
viewers will remember we may be clear we
understood which side the DNC was on
that they were not playing it fairly and
they weren't playing it objectively but
we had to take and this is important and
this is what gives me confidence in the
future in my campaign and we talked
about this a great deal in the book we
had to take on the entire Democratic
establishment we are to take on every
governor every mayor the entire
Democratic Party in the US Senate with
the exception of Senator Merkley of
Oregon very few members in the House of
Representatives supported me so we had
to take them all on
and yet we ended up winning 22 states
getting thirteen point four million
votes getting 46% of all pledged
delegates and by the way we ended up
winning in every state the young people
black Latino white Asian American a
Native American so we had to take them
on I'm confident and I feel good about
what we accomplished but obviously the
political revolution has got to continue
going forward our revolution is Bernie
Sanders fourth book and book TV has
covered all four of his books outsider
in the house was his first in 1998 the
speech came out in 2011 that was his
filibuster and outsider in the White
House just came out last year and now
our revolution is out this year have you
talked to Donald Trump since the
election no I have not next call is Jean
in Oakland California
although our senator Sanders yep I'm
glad to see that you are taking
leadership is troubling in confusing
times we they're disappointed you know
that you are not actually elected
president we have the opposite of you in
the White House and it's a very scary
prospect you know the next four years
God blesses you my question is what do
you think might happen to Social
Security in Medicare under Trump is
there a possibility that they may be
privatized or got it and what can the
Democrats okay the answer to the
question is the American people
overwhelmingly not only do not not only
do they not want to see Social Security
cut not only do they not want to see
Social Security privatized what the
American people want is to see Social
Security expanded because they know that
disabled veterans and senior citizens
and people with disabilities cannot make
it on ten eleven twelve thousand dollars
a year now Trump as I mentioned earlier
during his campaign in order to get
votes he said I Donald Trump I'm not
going to cut Social Security Medicare
and Medicaid but what I know and I think
you know is that in the Republican Party
right now you have all kinds of people
who are salivating at the prospect of
cutting social security or privatizing
Social Security of converting Medicare
into a voucher program so the question
is whether Trump will keep faith with
the American people whether he will keep
his word or not but I will tell you that
we are going to do everything we can to
rally the American people not to cut
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
too many people in America today are
living in poverty they are living in
desperation they can't afford their
prescription drugs and we are not going
to cut programs that will like the death
of so many Americans from our revolution
senator this is a sentence I think that
Donald Trump would agree with our
infrastructure is crumbling one of the
most important parts of your
agenda was creating millions of new jobs
by rebuilding our infrastructure yes
there is no question that our
infrastructure is collapsing
that is our roads our bridges I was in
Flint Michigan during the campaign
what's happening there with the water
system is unspeakable what's going on
to some degree all over this country we
used to have the best rail system in the
world the longer the case
airports are deteriorating levees and
dams we can create I proposed a trillion
dollar investment over a five-year
period which would create 13 million
decent paying jobs mr. Trump has been
talking about rebuilding the
infrastructure I hope his ideas are not
simply giving tax breaks to corporations
so we end up privatizing our roads and
our bridges that would be a disaster but
if he is serious about rebuilding our
infrastructure and creating jobs that's
a positive idea that we can go forward
with but I might add to this when we
talk about infrastructure mr. Trump
during his campaign told the American
people that he thought that climate
change was a hoax was a hoax well let me
just be as clear as I can be I'm a
member of the US Senate Committee on the
environment I thought to scientists all
over the world climate change is not a
hoax climate change is a threat to this
entire planet it is caused by human
activity and if we do not get our act
together in the very near future and
transform our energy system away from
fossil fuel to energy efficiency and
sustainable energy we're going to see
more droughts more flood or extreme
weather disturbances more acidification
of the ocean we are here in Miami Beach
Florida more rising sea levels that will
threaten this very city here and mr.
Trump I hope I hope is smart enough to
know that he has to listen to the
scientists and not just the fossil fuel
industry time for a couple more calls
Stephen large Mountain New York go ahead
hi there Steve or little I'll go ahead
hi I am Hawaiian favor
good Burnie and I'm very much proud of
you and I'm very much in favor of what
you've stood for but as a public I think
we're all asking for one thing that is
to all of us try to work together and
reduce the rhetoric because the noise
because we need healing we need to pull
together it's not the idea that it
shouldn't be us against them or them
against us I think if we could all work
together I think all of us are smart
enough to make it happen what do you
think well I think Steve that there is
much more commonality among the American
people than the media allows us to
believe I'm not going to say that there
are not people in this country people
are watching this program we're not
going to disagree with me and others on
abortion rights I am strongly pro-choice
on gay marriage I believe in gay
marriage on a number of other issues but
on the other hand Steve if you look at
issues like raising the minimum wage pay
equity for women we just talked about
rebuilding our crumbling infrastructure
making college affordable for all of our
all of our young people demanding that
the wealthy and large corporations start
paying their fair share of taxes you
would be surprised
and how many progressives and
conservatives share similar views on
many of those issues at the end of the
day if you're a conservative you know
you want to see your kid be able to go
to college you want to earn a decent
wage so I think in many ways there is
more commonality than the media allows
us to believe and Donna in Irvine
California you get the last word with
senator Sanders hello senator Sanders
we're listening please go ahead
oh hi senator Sanders I have a question
yeah hi
the question I have congratulations on
your book
I want to know my question is do you
have any regrets I want to add to that
I'm glad you did the book you're you're
phenomenal anyway
leader do you have any any really wife
Donna we are out of town time and let's
get an answer from senator Sanders oh
well I didn't quite get the question but
Donna thank you very much for your kind
words and I hope people take a take the
time to read the book and you know but
the book is about is not just the
campaign what we try to do in the book
is give very common-sense practical
solutions to the major crises that we
face the economy health care criminal
justice immigration reform climate
change and so forth so let's end with
one political question Tim Ryan and
Nancy Pelosi do you have a dog in that
fight at all well Nancy is a friend of
mine and you know it Tim's views of Oh
Tim Ryan I'm sorry I think Paul Ryan
right no I'm intellect I was in the
house for a number of years but I will
let the Democrats in the house sort that
one senator Bernie Sanders our
revolution a future to believe in here's
the cover of the book in a little over
an hour
senator Sanders will be speaking live on
book TV in the book TV room here at the
Miami block well coming up next a
call-in program with retired general
Andrew bacevich whose book is about the
Middle East and America's wars in the
Middle East and that's coming up in just
a few minutes